good day be home by dinner I love you
morning Catherine
and here are your daughters Angela and
Catherine about seven hours ago and
that's the last information we have
Catherine Angela if you if you hear this
hey you found her
we and Catherine are doing on Daniel's
Woods you're just walking and walking so
I remember Angela can you tell your dad
how long you were gone a few hours
baby you've been gone three days
laughs
[Music]
what'd you say I didn't say nothing
sorry I heard you say something
hey baby
okay
wherever those girls when they brought
something back with them the body and
the blood of Jesus Christ
put it in the blood the body in the
blood
Catherine body in the blood
the body in the blood the body and the
blood Catherine
[Applause]
have you ever seen anything like this
not me no but there are people out there
who have
[Applause]
you have some experience with a
possession yes more than that life
I believe you can help get our girls
back
exorcism is a ritual every culture every
religion they all use different methods
it's going to take all of them
[Music]
we've met before
mother
[Applause]
[Music]
what did you do
is that Catherine's heartbeat they're
beating in shape
God played a trick on me
[Music]